bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors seront
confinement est ce que c'est une bonne
décision selon vous bonjour tout le
monde
c'est le mois on peut dire que l'en
après l'impression qu'il a beaucoup
avancé dans la prise en charge comme il
s'inscrit lui annonce forcément une aux
dames très dramatique parce qu'il est le
nouveau virus serait pas trop cool
traité comme moins qu'ils bissonnier
c'était une session de dramatique est
compliqué aujourd'hui peine un an après
anne italie on a l'impression qu'on a
perdu et non puis il n'était préparé
pour la deuxième ou troisième bac et
même la campagne de vaccination à
l'essor des quelques fourmis dans les
décisions qui font vacciner les
priorités le moment c'était les
personnels de santé les personnels et
les personnes âgées mais non on parlera
plutôt de l'école des transmissions ou
de la corruption publique
après on parle aussi du problème des des
provisions du bureau dé tous et ils
tuent rythme et au débat l'ancien
responsable des lacaunais chargé du
combinat qu'il y avait un visage et même
d'avoir des pétales célian des centres
de vaccination mais non retour la
vaccination dans les hôpitaux minusa la
nation consacré il aspirait parce que
justement la population qui était espéré
est ce que c'est un gros confinement qui
est nécessaire au monde parle en italie
la situation mais les premiers c'est sûr
que les normands ils sont mille traders
augmenté mais on a l'impression que
dauphine c'est vraiment des stratégies
c'est ça qui est qui est déplorable
aujourd'hui parce que je pourrais dire
qu'ils ont ré le confine qui commet pour
combien de temps et là il a quatre
semaines on le disait les taux sont à un
bas on parle de découvrir le théâtre
les messins des sports de mulhouse man
mars et quelques jours
révélant aussi dit c'est très grave où
je serai donc c'est surtout c'est qu'on
vit dans le brouillard qui brouille les
pistes qui exaspèrent les gens à ce que
surtout l'évolution libérant les
restaurateurs les à leurs espoirs qu'ils
ont fait les grands investissements
pareillement verbinski j à
on a l'impression vraiment qu'ils ont
fait lé petit cabotage et ça c'est très
vous pensez que votre pays a des
consignes est beaucoup trop tôt pour moi
c'est pas l'histoire autres taux celles
qui ont été confinés salon des lignes
strictes par exemple par rapport aux
gérants des écoles ont pu prévoir que
les écoles secondaires ou au plus tard
dans la journée vous éviter la multitude
des personnes et décidé aussi une
campagne du tri-nations s'il agite aussi
de la médecine préventive la médecine
famille est complètement oublié
cardiaque et donc les médecins pour des
problèmes aussi des responsabilités
médicales il prêt à prendre des risques
du coup les patients ils vont à engorger
les urgences il porte un corset des
hôpitaux et du coup ça fait un effet le
bouchon et tout ça ça crée aussi des
détentions l'encodeur pour les classes
des vidéos peeters d'un courriel on a
l'impression qu'il manque ou vraiment
une stratégie de même qu'anne drague
arrivée lite est saluée par tous les
forces politiques il un gosse à pipe
politique
à l'opposé décanter mais même ça on
espérer de voir une stratégie plus
correct et pour le mans 74 mais non il y
a les militaires qui sont pris en charge
la stratégie de la vaccination et les
confinements d'un camp où on attend de
voir si l'allemagne est le changement
depuis la montée justement la stratégie
la stratégie de vaccination tel bilan
vous fait et comment expliquer la
lenteur de la campagne vaccinale dans la
péninsule
et le bilan est vraiment catastrophique
déjà dans la commande des taxes est dans
ça vous fait des plus uniques vaccinera
nouvelle affaire aussi décider qui va
signer comment ou mais ça en a
trois fois des mois les plaintes de
vaccination c'est aussi ça prouve qu'il
n'y a pas eu
ils tablent déjà long terme en décide on
vaccine les personnes âgées melodys
cription départ les personnes âgées leur
existence internet au lieu des choses
qui sont contradictoires
après les pour les médecins mais ça ça
nous touche personnellement
les médecins des hôpitaux d'une tête
tous vaccinés rapidement mais nous les
libérerons des compléments biais on
attend lors d'un médecin devant nous
qu'on montre et vous avez suscité un
beau 10 seulement que les autres le mal
est pris en compte des ménages aidés
pour vous qu'il ya des patients qui sont
actionnaires de moi et là la campagne
c'est plutôt les profs d'école donc très
bien une décision c'est les profs
d'école qui doit être vacciné en
priorité c'est les personnes en santé
c'est le personnes âgées et chaque
semaine a l'impression que le chef de la
stratégie par rapport à des lobbys qui
font des pressions
vous avez réussi à vous vacciner vous
c'est l'heure de médecins qui gèrent ça
met tout le monde à bien une première
vague un tram et des personnels au
dessous des 60 ans kim été vaccinés et
maintenant sort de l'homme mardi les
biens de vaccination c'est que sont
catastrophiques
donc ça aussi c'est une région dont j'ai
rappelé à sa sauce alors concerner
encore la vaccination prend enfin un
espoir un du gouvernement qui affirme
que 80% de la population sera vaccinée
d'ici septembre
en france on est un peu dans le même cas
de figure puisque les autorités parlent
d'une vaccination de la population toute
la population d'ici fin août
est-ce que concernant votre pays c'est
réaliste
c'est peut-être la liste mais les des
principaux problèmes c'est quel type de
vaccin comment va s'approvisionner l'axé
mais là il ya une grosse espoirs sont
légion ces gens sont passés parce qu'il
est saisi lui seul 2 et après voilà ce
qui évite les stratégies comment voir
maxime et qui va vacciner
est-ce qu'ils vont rester le kent dans
les hôpitaux st leu médecins libéraux
n'étaient pas vaccinés
et stylisé dernière paire maxime et
voyait tout ça c'est encore décidé il
n'y a pas un véritable patrie gsk
motorisés les salles de sport les écoles
qui sort actuellement fermé pour faire
des cintres des partis nationaux
ça c'est des questions à laquelle on n'a
pas les réponses mais les médecins de
famille ils n'ont pas le dos aux matinée
n'ont pas été vaccinés en un parti me
martin ans est entré chez région perd sa
source
donc oui challenge mouche à chaque fois
on a des effets de l'os mais après
est-ce que ça suive est-ce que
l'intendance suive
non ça par contre on attend nouveaux
tanks mais nous en tant que médecin on
n'aime pas d'éclair qu'ils vont vous
dire voilà à partir de ce moment-là
vaccinés qui aiment trop vite et qu'il
faut vacciner
l'unique espoir que je sais qu'elle est
en tout cas on sait qu'ils les
coronavirus ils vont décéder biogas avec
l'arrivée du printemps et donc
effectivement uni en irak printemps elle
était pour ainsi dire à taper le mémo
comparé à un moment mais faire un look
d'art globale pour remercier tout le
monde n'a pas le bac cette box et à ses
diamants stratégie claire et nette
merci beaucoup à vous berthod giovannini
je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
chirurgien